got an email from Ukraine the other day
business owner 35 runs an IT company
recently decided jeans and t-shirt don't
cut it anymore not quite sure how to
make that changeover to business our
tire work common problem let's solve it
okay Vlad listen up the basics you need
two suits make that three one navy one a
bit of a lighter blue and one grey like
this one no stripes no patterns make
sure it's good quality wool take them to
a tailor have them altered to you easy
next shirts you need six three white
ones three in different shades of blue
no patterns no stripes leave that for
the ties you need six of those two plain
ones one red one blue striped checked
dotted done
now do the math this will give you 36
different combinations that means you
can go to work for nearly two months
without wearing the same outfit twice I
have two or three pairs of decent shoes
Oxford's brogues by the best you can
afford one more thing take your time
when making the change from sloppy to
smart start out wearing a suit maybe
twice a week and slowly increase the
frequency that will also give your
colleagues time to adjust
just ignore their comments what else do
you expect from guys a dress like
teenagers